right flashpoint ebon test man what do
we have going on here who do we have
here with us a special guest in the
house so those of you guys have been out
in the gaming world at all in the
YouTube this guy has been doing it for a
while now definitely had an explosion
shout-out to his growth recently
definitely well deserved but the man of
the intros I can't do this as well
definitely not gonna claim to be but the
man of the intro is Lord Cognito let's
go ahead and get our special guest his
introduction and get him going so yeah
we got we got to the building so we got
to do we got to get a long podcast
treatment right now so welcome to the
realm of flashpoint episode number 40
and it's a glorious Saturday afternoon
and we are back at the round table here
on Destiny's date I'm extremely excited
about our special guest so we're gonna
get right into it I want to introduce a
Lord whose meteoric rise as a destiny
content creator has truly been
remarkable to watch knowing that this
Lord continually have his finger on the
pulse of the community but his passion
is everything everything he does from
this amazing weapon versus series raid
guys for dummies and weapon set rankings
and try dancing that creative host of
the cactus HD YouTube channel and recent
member of the 700 thousand subscriber
Club Destiny's true king of the north
when it comes to passion humor and
honesty and today making his debut into
the realm of flashpoint
mommy Lord Rick cactus HD how you doing
sir doing good thing he didn't
understand that lord of the intros there
oh my god no no that's why I was like I
totally passed that bar to him because
definitely can't keep up it's great
let's go cactus is gonna build up a huge
famine first of all how you doing man
I'm doing good I'm doing good no doubt
man good good to have you in here go
talk some destiny have some fun so let's
get into a baby bus what we got going
man uh well I mean got a very a good
tweet to talk about we'll get to that
one later from a very you know
high-ranking individual
we've got 12
talk about we've got thunder Lord that
everybody has been enjoying videos
coming out about that it has been kind
of a really fun gun to use getting it a
little lackluster but we'll get into
those pieces and we finally got official
dates for what is to come next yeah so
not too much going on we'll jump into
this week at Bungie so many you guys
know Thunder Lord is here Oh so first
thing for those of you guys that have it
let's talk about it
how's the gun Oh bad thing first of all
I got a shout-out cactus on this one I
mean I saw his video and I said let me
get this hurry up get this uh Ives quest
done and man it is even better than I
thought it was with this big is amazing
I will let khakis Jeffie because he's
got some great uh versus videos in a
Content on how you feeling about the
bullet man it's not like it's one of
those is one of the very few weapons
where you know obviously I'm testing it
and tested it and a couple of raids now
and stuff and the just it has some perks
that lend it to single target damage you
know where you shoot a target and it'll
start lightening training even if it's
just one target which is super important
and also the increasing rate of fire
like so it's really good against dpsing
like a single target so much so that you
know you're able to choose a Riven
you're able to I could just smelt
scalice like it just so much stuff right
and if we were to compare like the upper
echelon of exotic weapons especially
exotic heavy weapons we do have the
whisper yes and we do have the sleeper
and they're unreal but the thing is is
like you can use your Thunder Lord
against the massive amount of just the
load to your ads that also spawn you
can't do that with the whisper you can't
do that with the sleeper like in a pinch
if you need to kill it like the
seventeen thralls charging at you or the
seventeen Cylons or whatever you need to
do thunder Lord will melt them all you
know you don't want to be whispering
them you don't want to be sleeping them
and so that's the power of the Thunder
Lord is like it's amazing a DPS I don't
think it's quite sleeper level but it's
close but it's all so unreal
at AG clearing its way beyond obviously
the sleeper level there it's more like
it's like a sun shot like a 62 the
magazine Sun shot mm-hmm double down on
what you're saying because um I think
the key for it from me was I I expected
it to be good you know against he had
stuff like that but like you said single
target dps when you get those extra
lightning strikes it all it almost has
an outbreak prime kind of feel like
we're dealing with a single target dps
way like remember the nanites used to
come to get additional damage not
getting these extra lightning you know
that kind of stuff is pretty cool and
just like you said I mean just low-level
ad clearing and those extra explosion
with a Sun shot kind of a feel it is so
versatile
that's what surprised it's the
versatility of the weapon really
impressed me how much did you get a
chance to touch you know if I just win
it oh man like it's as you were saying
it's just the idea that you can clear so
many ads so quickly but then turn around
and look at a heavy guy and oh it feels
like I almost melt him just as fast yeah
the gun is insanely powerful you see the
crits going down like a orange bar
majors just health is falling off and
you switch over to a boss and everybody
dies fast to this gun it's honestly been
so much fun but I mean as Rick saying
it's late you get the versatility of it
as you're saying you sleeper and whisper
yeah that single shot but yeah you can
turn shoot a couple ads and then turn
right back without having to switch
weapons and keep going on the boss just
its versatility I mean they definitely
started really powerful with a heavy
machine gun which kind of makes me
wonder if the others lengthy ones coming
in black armory or even gonna be as
remotely as good what you probably won't
be like is this the Best Exotic heavy
and air power in the game like activity
and you doing a strike and stuff like
that like if you're doing gambit there's
an argument for some of the stuff but if
you're doing a strike if you're doing
even like a raid if you're doing
whatever you're doing
um flashpoint whatever you're gonna use
a thunderlord I don't see why not
I literally can't tell you why not I
mean the only thing unless you're just
trying to really snipe something at
range maybe you just want to go whisper
but you have so many bullets in this
thing just just start shooting you'll
kill it that's your like like you know
if you're doing specifically eater of
worlds or whatever maybe whisper maybe
that but it's very specific encounters
yeah man and now I beat myself
completely blown away
really lovely gun but I have some to say
about the quest okay well here's another
can of worms master Ives mystery the
crazy hyped thing what do you think
great quest right I got the world y'all
like listen you know I thought them
trying to make a murder mystery thing in
connection with Festival the lost was a
cool concept okay cool I never liked
that cryptarch anyway so let's see who
killed them okay fine so much yeah it's
the old IOP I used to get I would I
never got fair credit those house
banners I used to turn into him I've
always thought all gave me more but
that's not story yeah that's just like
okay cool and then we all know how
simple the steps were okay cool but I
thought it would be more of a payoff
floor wise you know you know going to
the Cosmodrome dope like d1 feels
nostalgia you get there you know we kind
of got the bullet sponge kind of boss a
little bit more health than usual and
again it's just I didn't felt like I got
any real conclusion besides the fact
that we saw her eyes banner you know on
top of the teleporter just I don't know
I just
it just felt lore wise weak but that's
just me what did you feel - hard on it I
think hmm
like it wasn't that unbelievable of a
quest if you think about like you know
it was it was spread out between three
weeks and the first two weeks were kind
of a joke the last week made up for it a
little bit going back to the cosmodrome
was was sweet like just just it was very
nostalgic it worked like it's one of
those things where if they brought back
the cosmodrome in potentially a
different way they'd be getting
criticized for rescanning and stuff and
for being lazy but for this specifically
because it's like an old weapon and
stuff
that and you know it
technically in this place in the
cosmodrome is where the Thunderer
dropped in that trailer like before
destiny ever released thanks so that is
very nostalgic um but I think like you
know it was technically this quest for a
free event it was a you know it's not
just randomly part of forsaken it's a
quest having to do with the festival of
the lost so it didn't necessarily have
to be huge I think part of its downfall
was you know it kind of got discovered
in the database and then yeah I mean ya
know it was like baited for like four
weeks straight so everyone was expecting
some insane things uh and and then that
kind of I think just the hype of the
community was the downfall of this quest
if everything would have like been kept
secret mmm I think it would have been
like a lot more positively received I
see we going what you say but I do agree
like I think they could have done a
little bit more especially with the
first two quest steps like you know no I
agree I agree what did you feel about
the quest itself uh I mean I'm pretty
much in agreement with you guys on a lot
of pieces as you said the nostalgia was
cool going back to cosmodrome and
honestly a little cuz the five scandals
you've got out there those were probably
the most insight we've ever had to
holiday just to see a little bit of her
thoughts on things she was actually the
one in the car with the two skeletons
was like almost sad those pieces were
kind of cooled as you said the nostalgia
coming back to the cosmodrome was
literally like a throwback five years to
e3 trailers and stuff like that so I
mean that was really cool but I also
think as you said it's like the quest
steps could have just had more it didn't
have to be crazy but hey go get ten
pages okay maybe you go here's a quest
on each planet to go get a couple of
them decrypted and like you just give
you a little more pieces to do so
there's a little more length to it cuz
it was like go do one public event you'd
almost have it done okay and then it was
literally almost as quick it was like if
you burn through the lost sectors
because I did them all together I was
like we literally ran down super team
ran down super human ran down super to
him and then like one to the other it
was like you could have the whole asset
cookies done in another
it's just sorry you didn't even have to
go to the EDC you could just like go to
start just by a bunch engrams and of the
lost pages like sweet yeah just yeah
just it didn't have the feel like the
nostalgia was cool going back but just a
little more a little more as all I think
a lot of people were asking but yeah I
think the biggest piece was I mean caki
said it right was the spoiler everybody
knew this thing was coming if we
wouldn't have known and finally were
like hey bunnies like go see what's out
there they literally tweeted like an
hour later go get your Thunder Lord like
shot the dizzy to check he said why was
a man to holiday chief inspector he said
uh considering the reward for the murder
mystery at least it's worth doing it
wasn't as good as it currently is
I'd be it'd be a bit of a waste of time
yeah I agree again I do feel like
actually saying with the date of mind
being hurt because we didn't know about
it but like you said he brothers when
Bunty themselves are like go get it
you know it's like okay this big mystery
that you know you caught kind of hype it
up to be but I don't want to complain
too much yeah it's only the time I good
point just now I was like like it's
weird hey not that insane of a quest um
connected this free event but what was
another random secret quest that came
out the led to an exotic was the whisper
one and that was nuts
nuts and compared to that this is trash
like is everything gonna be a whisper
quest you know not necessarily I don't
know sounds like it can't be all that
good but like I'm saying whisper for me
it was like one of the coolest moments
of I mean for definitely in a while but
something else we need to think of of
this quest right is this is not
necessarily a whisper type quest in its
design as like this crazy secret hidden
exotic this entire quest is a teaser for
next season
right now one of the biggest things
Bungie is doing next season is bringing
back machine guns so getting an exotic
machine gun that's really really good in
everyone's hands
this is kind
of a marketing strategy right like this
is kind of like a little bit of a teaser
right in in the best possible way for us
players I wish they did like marketing
teasers looks more similar to this is
giving us an exotic weapon but again you
can't make it too hard because you want
almost every des teams player to go out
and get this weapon and say this thing's
amazing
and then when budgie says guess what we
got more of these machine guns coming in
black arm where you're like oh my god
and you're like signing up you're like
shoving your credit card onto your
screen and you're really excited for the
next expansion because of this weapon so
you got to think of it that way it can't
be too hard cuz then it doesn't work as
like a teaser for the next season hmm I
see we going with it I mean listen it's
great promo I agree which I mean you
know it's one of those things you
setting up the new DLC I get that aspect
I'm actually you know cool with in that
regard again maybe I'm um am I being a
little selfish because of the you know
we got things like whisper maybe you
know I just was hoping that you know
there was more clarity with the actual
story behind the mystery you know I'm
saying again that just might get
nitpicking in reference to that but
overall the gun itself absolutely
amazing machine gun there's a new weapon
type coming back to destiny absolutely
i'm hype for it like I was saying I mean
the marking started it worked on me like
I'm so hyped for machine guns now I
really want to see what they're doing
with the legendary machine guns they
bring back like the BTR D it's done yeah
Maz was a was a quill um terminus
long-term and if that was the King :
yeah baby yeah it was based it was I
just remember it's like and I like we
talked about this a little before it's
like in PDP that was my go-to as heavy
machine guns because the amount of you
only need to three or four bullets to
kill each person and the fact that you
could run around and get like five or
six kills just spread that clip out it
was so much I just like pick up the
heavy mo wait for everybody waste all
the rockets and then go into the mix and
just start destroying everybody yeah now
if you're the only one getting it as
opposed to d1 you're just gonna wreak
like five people without trying I'm
watching
question do you think now with machine
guns reintroduced that we will finally
get armor that will have specific
machine gun perks I think it'll come
with black armory I'm wondering if like
I think it'll come with like army I hope
it's a retro actively applied so it's
like you can go back and get you know
dreaming city legendary armor that can
now you know randomly roll with those
machine gun perks that you want instead
of just you have to get the new black
army armor you know in the purple now
hopefully it's that much fun
that'll be cool yeah he'll be cool I
mean yeah it's like especially as people
are still gonna be doing the old raid
like shattered thrown stuff like that
they need to make sure again because
that's one thing we're asking about to
the more perks the better so if you're
more reasons to go get drops everywhere
for this type of stuff that'll be good
mhm
so does we got man what's going on so I
mean yeah thunderlord's beast mode quest
was but yeah I was like they're not all
gonna be amazing but if you did get your
Thunder Lord which helped flavor but you
did you got a crazy long sleeved t-shirt
with are you gonna have to get this one
with your four horsemen of gaming
holding your face right to you oh that
is so me like that is literally like one
of our designs we have like a horse with
a gaming thing the eye Lords that's
that's the next line are coming up of
t-shirts and Bungie beat me to it
I think spy I gotta get that done the
lord rocky oh yeah it's gonna be so
exclusive how you have to get it thunder
learn how difficult this is gonna be
rare than that jacket with a shoot
that's like I'm gonna be wearing my my
week 1 ray jacket and it was like yeah
but you have the thunderlord shirt like
cool design I just I'm not a huge
long-sleeve person so I'm still trying
to decide but it is there so I might
have to do it but I like the design
though it is pretty cool yeah well yeah
that's me - you like my biceps are so
freakin huge like I don't think
I've been busted I'll be making it at
irregardless I'm just kidding get some
tickets for Rick's gun show this is
gonna be crazy
he's got guys ready say he said that
that that I can't hold so here's the
question just with regards to the date
of this quest the quest ends in 10 days
so unlike whisper that's literally there
every weekend over and over after you
know the season ends it's just in the
like exotic loot pool so then if you
don't get it or you were out of town for
two weeks or something like that I mean
do you think it should always be a quest
available just to get or do you think
it's okay with a gonna dilute pool what
do you guys think I'll jump in it I
think for me I thought the way they
handle it like it almost seemed like
limited time at first so I was assuming
okay they're trying to promo getting
everybody back on the game right between
DLC release and kind of like do it that
way and I was curious to see okay if it
goes away then what happens it was that
you can't ever get it so I mean it's
gonna go into cool like you said and um
I don't know I'm indifferent to be
honest like I'm not like pissed off that
you know it's going in that people
shouldn't be able to get it like you
know obviously if you were out of town
you know this at this period when they
did they did it then you would be
screwed you know say so you know I do
want other people to experience the gun
so I mean I guess I guess that's okay
I'm not really either away with this
like I'm not like angry I'm not like
super happy what do you feel Rick like
how you feel I'm fine with it like the
quest is pretty easy so if you're out of
town for an entire like month or
whatever yeah you might get screwed over
I think like I kind of imagined anyone
like who really really wanted it
wouldn't be able to get it right it'd be
like people who really aren't paying
attention to like any part of the game
um like I'm sure there's some exceptions
like I don't want to see like make it
seem like you know someone still might
not end up screwed but it's not going
away forever it's just being put in the
loop pool like it'll be harder to get
but it's not like UNAC wire belay make
it as common as year one exotics and
then he'll drop all the time
believe me we've been all over that so
it's like I'm you know you've had your
thoughts we've had our discussions on it
like just a quick little tip but when
you talk about year one exotics are you
add for or against like where they're at
right now with the drop rate just a
quick thought from you well when we
finish eating this thing I've been
trying till I subtly eat in the
background go to well it'd be inches I
think that I mean for me I got the
shards of gallon or like oh I tweet it
out about it um I saw you tweet must
have been a few days ago you know um and
that was my first piece first piece of
forsaken exotic armor right and it's not
like I don't play the damn game I played
quite a bit and like you first of that
like that's my first one like that's
pretty insane um and so for me I don't
mind it being a low drop rate it makes
exotic special and it's what I was
asking for um back you know back in
vanilla d2 or sorry vanilla d1 like when
you saw some with things otic you were
genuinely like you like what what is
that was ideal Monte Carlo like what
what the what is that yeah and it was so
cool
like I remember wouldn't be for when we
were first doing the vault of glass
someone had a hard light and like all
the rest five of us were like all
crowding around and watching him shoot
he's a kick bounces off [ __ ] oh my god
and it really just like it made exotic
so special so I don't mind them doing
that in this game like it's annoying but
when you do get one like when I got my
shards you you feel like amazing right
and that's the positive but I think they
should have introduced that exotic
protection that they introduced on the
30th what like on the start cuz if
you're gonna make exotic super rare
don't add RNG on top of RNG and also
make it so you know you're getting all
these year ones you have no like
protection from stuff you've already got
you have no duplicate protection and dad
insult injury every time you complete an
exotic quest you're reducing your
chances to get the energy war like it
was like three things going against you
and I felt that was that was a little
too much so this drop rate but with some
duplicate protection and not you know
inflating the loop pool of stuff you
don't want right that should have been
in since the start I agree I got a
question for you as I want to flip that
as a content creator look at it's like
how do you feel because remember a lot
of us we go to you I will like okay the
new exotic came out you know cap is
gonna put it through its paces you know
so because of this drought rate as the
content creator the how do you feel
about does that affect you because you
can't do these will get these reviews
are up and you know and then challenge
it was so bad I didn't even bother with
reviews I mean most people who put up
reviews were just boring people's
accounts and I mean you gotta do what
you gotta do right and I don't think
there's anything necessarily wrong with
that cuz it's like I mean how how are
you gonna put up all these different
exotic things and in when there's such
bad drop rates like it's impossible to
get them yourself you have to bore
people's accounts but then you don't
actually get that much time with the
weapon right becomes account you play a
few rounds with it and you try to put up
a video it's still a good explanation of
kind of the baseline values of a weapon
mm-hmm and how it kind of acts but it's
not a real you can't ever really be
super in-depth unless the person you're
boring their account lets you like have
for an entire day basically so it can it
can create some problems with the super
low drop rate but at the end of the day
I kind of just you know pasted it out
when I could when I was I was luckier
with the weapons like I did get the true
I did get a decent amount of weapons so
I was doing the raid versus with those
when I got them like the Cerberus and so
on
but yeah like it definitely it
definitely makes things challenging with
this low drop rates for sure
interesting no Janice want to know your
perspective on it but you get eat uh so
well-seasoned of a forge we finally have
an official date I I do have to say
though we'll get down to where it's
actually listed at but do you guys like
how they drop the date for this one mmm
interesting right it's literally just
like it's where I got to find it flip of
the coin it's somewhere it's literally
just in a paragraph yeah it's down here
so we know it is December 4th will be
black armor it is official season the
forge will begin on the 27th that's
they're kind of three weeks and with
same way they did forsaken your week of
buffer while they kind of iron stuff out
and turn one off before they turn one on
we'll get our Vidak on the 27th which is
also the closest we're ever gonna have
and a full gameplay calendar so show us
what comes with season 2 the forge but
as we're still waiting and I was talking
to cactus about they're not cactus sorry
you're on the mind I was talking to
Cognito about this as well and he's
giving me a hard time but just um my
thoughts although this is the fact that
we've never had this short of a
marketing window I mean I know as you
said thunderlord is kind of doing a
little bit of that but as this is the
annual pass first time we're seeing it
we're gonna get a week before this thing
comes out to know what we're gonna get
so what do you guys think overall just
with the timing of the release and just
from the little bit that we've seen so
far a little more than a week right like
we've got little over a week until the
27th and then it's another week until
the 4th right yep so they're gonna be
teasing stuff mm-hmm like up to the 20
set they're gonna be teasing stuff
starting like now starting today
basically you know what I mean like
there's gonna be stuff start coming out
next week and the week after and then up
to the 4th mm-hmm so I mean it's I don't
think it's that condensed but it's a
little condensed but that's kind of the
thing now like that that's the new
that's a new like trend is like release
stuff right away don't have like these
trailers that you know hey two months
from now you get
this you haven't liked much much closer
to release yeah I mean I mean well hold
on sorry sorry to interrupt like a good
example like I mean for call of duty um
when you're in in call duty World War 2
and stuff there'd be like a new event
where it's like new weapons like changes
you know the look of the entire game
it's like that the st. Patrick's Day
event all this crazy stuff where the
zombies are forever they would announce
that stuff like that day of it would be
like the trailer would come out the day
the event goes live so it was like it's
here here's what it is go play it now
it's very like there's the era of the
trailer that teases something coming in
a few months is over it's like
everything happens very quickly now
right I mean I mention this because
really branches have gone back and forth
did a very tense subject being playfully
tease each other and I get it bounces
his point you know I know he's like
looking like you know stings coming out
we haven't really got much info and
based on previous cycles you know they
tended to UM always kind of like give us
those those reveals and those hints and
stuff much earlier and for me the way I
looked at it was just like okay you know
when forsaken dropped in my opinion this
has been the most consistent continual
like um update to a game at everyone
forsaken you had the bomb did the
release then boom you got the raid then
oh man the city's changing oh man a
shattered throne oh man now we got fist
and festival like it was this constant
you know new cycle during the content of
forsaken which I have never seen before
and we all commended Bungie like wow
this is amazing it feels like this every
week there's something else to do right
so as that's going on and now we have
you know armed black army and all that
stuff and now they're introducing this
thing called season like if you look at
the tribe it's like the season he's in
the drifter so I just think this is a
shift honestly and the way they are
presenting and then yes for destiny fans
we're used to getting me
a little early for the DLC trap but I do
got it in you know this is the new
pattern this is a new thing that they're
trying to implement and honestly first
they don't have a problem I mean we just
got done the Lord you got some stuff to
do it's not like in the past we just had
those droughts when you blaze the dlc
and then it's like nothing right so
you're just sitting there like okay
what's next
you know I feel you know I feels a
little different and I really I honestly
don't have a problem I think we're gonna
get some teasers I think I'm gonna get
you know some stings sprinkled out on
Twitter and you know bungees Instagram
account or whatever they do and I think
they'll get that going but I will say
this to ebon sees his defense I do feel
that there is a lot of pressure on black
harmony only from the standpoint
forsaking was so good so good so you
know will it reach you know for second
that was probably not but it needs to be
a solid DLC there's a lot of pressure
because like Activision said there's a
lot of people who are still on the fence
you know that didn't jump in on for a
second and they need to see I put it
this way it's like we can't have a curse
of Osiris ruled it now post forsaken
yeah I'm gonna slightly disagree with
what you're saying about having
something to do every week like it's
definitely good when it's a high to the
corruption week you see a lot of people
log on but the other two weeks I'm
finding like you know not too many
people are coming on and I think we're
really missing we just need one more
event like some sort like a um like a
monthly faction rally type of event yeah
I've got one you might be able to add to
that there's this this thing with the
gunsmith one one more little thing
because there has been you know when
it's not again when it's not a head of
the corruption you see the player base
kind of really drop off because there's
not that much to do and I mean that's
part of the problem with the exotic
dropper it being as low as it is and
especially before the duplicate
protection where it's like hey do you
mind just come on do some powerful gear
stuff and try to get your exotic no cuz
there's I have no chance like I have a
bet
winning the lottery right I think it's
definitely changing now but I think we
definitely need like one more yeah and
the return of faction rallies or
potentially trials something like that
just something else to do like one more
thing to do would really help I
understand where you're coming from that
and again my mindset with that is just
like look you know we were told already
that they weren't gonna be any you know
on trials this one while they work and
put it in you know under maintenance
construction cool you know I'm saying as
far as fracturing right I was surprised
that it didn't come back towards the end
of the cycle I'll give you that like I
thought we'd still get that this season
so they're still working on and tweaking
it and I get what you're going with that
like one more bit would probably round
things out but I don't know maybe it's
me it's just my play cadence maybe just
me seeing it on console I still see tons
of people I mean speaking on xbox I see
tons of people playing it when I look at
the Xbox top live almost play games list
it's in like the top five you know as
far as activity level at least on the
Xbox perspective I'm seeing that
activity maybe the other communities as
far as PC and ps4 may be different and
maybe that's what I'm not saying but I'm
good I mean and then we had you know
chat about like the whole the meatball
thing there's a lot of people that
didn't have malfeasance still that they
were unlucky then the drop rates got but
and I guess that's a height of the
corruption week right absolutely but
they also it's lit yeah but they also
increased it during those weeks when
they when it wasn't there
right that was another thing when it
wasn't corruption week people almost
felt like they had no chance and I got
mine during that and but also like to
your other question about yeah this
can't be another curse but like it's
impossible to be in the sense that you
know what there's randomly rolled
weapons now and that's such a huge thing
randomly rolled weapons and armor so
just it just adds to the depth of the
game so when they inevitably introduced
new weapons and they're randomly rolled
like it's gonna shake things up more
than just any sort of static rolled
trash prophecy weapons would in the past
also
but yeah III really hope they they bring
the content you know there's been the
rumors of the new the new weapon rarity
of like black weapons well we'll have to
see like are those gonna be better like
you know even more rare than exotics or
right between Legendary's and exotics or
a new type of Legendary's I mean for
goodness sakes the escalation shotgun is
ranked as a legendary and it is not it
is something different right so are they
gonna have those kind of unique
Legendary's I have those you know unique
perks like esque like the escalation are
those gonna be its own category that
kind of not quite exotics but kind of
close I don't know there's good stuff
man let me ask you guys both this um
what do you feel black armory needs to
do we only we've all agree we don't it
can't be a customer service kind of loan
and we know that you don't like these
new blow no black armor weapons are
coming it's this new category you know
what what do you feel it just has a deal
so you don't know that it was a rumour
Rumour correct correct but like what are
you what do we need from this dlc so we
can be satisfied as soon as a content
release well as always honors to the
guest first
well I did make a video called the five
things Buckeye Marie needs yeah I think
that I mean I mean that video I kind of
laid it all out so I'll try to kind of
repeat in short form what I said um I
think you know I think there needs to be
a good amount of brand new exotics I
don't want to see just a bunch of like
Oh less words back and icebreakers back
and you know all this crap is back I
much rather have brand new exotics I'm
with you there um and another thing is
that I really want to see I think my top
one was um I really really want to see
new perks like especially weapons out of
my mouth yep yeah something that can
compete with kill clip rampage like how
many rampage or how many kill clip
outlaw
rolls are you gonna try to get you only
mean like you go for so if you add all
these new weapons hey there's new pulse
rifles and auto rifles but um you know
black guy Marie hits and you get this
new black army auto rifle and you're
looking for rampage and you know
whatever as always it's not gonna last
as long it's not gonna feel special they
need to add some new perks that can
compete with those perks to really spice
up the new weapons I think and I think
that's a really really big thing yeah I
agree
I wanna shout out drew in a chat um we
actually had a good point I want new
exotic catalysts as well yes a lot of
guns that they still don't have them and
you know how cool it would I know for
one is I just got my lord of wolves so
like the guns great but it just burns
through to him hey Mon so fast I wish I
had her - it's like deeper ammo reserves
or something yeah it's a ton of cool
exotics there I'm door catalysts for
exotic armor all don't know I'm still
waiting on that oh my gosh cuz that's
kind of one of those pieces they just
got done hyping up the you know damage
types and the orbs and stuff but if you
throw a masterwork on you just lose all
that art not a masterwork thrown exotica
and you lose that piece and there was
supposed to be those at some point but
they've never gotten around to them so
I'm waiting for that I'm with you like
on perks cuz we have as you say it's
three like take the ones that they've
gotten realized not all of them are that
great and they need they need to get
buffed in some way for what we've got
but yeah catalyst did the other can you
imagine a thunder Lord or with master
work with that helm with enhanced heavy
lifting it's just like constant super
it's a beast mmm that'd be sick and in
the master work adds rampage I shot
three ads and then Riven just like is
just wave the white flag it's like I'm
done I'm out no I would say for me the
one thing I'm kind of looking for is for
them to do because there's gonna be this
other quote activity and what kind of
get to the list of what's in season of
the forge and the activity I think they
tried to bring in for
dreaming city was the blind well and
while at first it was cool grinding up
it's a way to get you know the level
four versions a way to get a piece of
powerful gear but once you've kind of
got your seeds of light from there and
stuff like that you don't need to grind
that anymore
and if they had that type of activity
like escalation protocol with its own
armor set maybe with specific perks with
its own weapons from that that have
maybe some perks give all of those
things its own like set of stuff to
grind for because if they do bring an
activity in but it's got nothing to go
with it it's still gonna fall off fairly
quick so that suppose that activity is
what I'm waiting to see what has that's
a really good point with like okay you
have an activity and you got per any of
you know rewards tied to it and usually
use the example of armor yeah like that
I think that's one of the things I was
handled really poorly in my opinion in
um Forsaken where you know you do the
raid and the raid armor is just normal
ass are more like it looks cool but what
happened to those intrinsic raid perks
that we saw eye candy one that should
absolutely you know even for the weapons
like whirlwinds curse where's the
world's with whirlwinds curse of
Forsaken and the armor that would make
you stronger in that raid you know you
know for the right a rattlin machine
they had the armor where you get
increased resistance when you're
carrying a score scan well a lot of the
raid involved you carrying a scorch
cannon potentially so having that
increased temperature distance made you
better obviously you know in the multi
glass head the weapons that did more
damage to Oracle's and stuff like I love
that and that's a great thing where if
you're doing the damn raid and earning
raid loot the raid loot should make you
better at the raid so you can go through
it and and then you know help other
people and all this stuff I want to see
that return and I really hope it does
with season of the forge like I hope if
the raid layer comes with the good armor
that has intrinsic perks like always
jobs or certain intrinsic perks that
makes you better in that raid lair yeah
I agree I think what has happened right
now is that they've taken kind of a
shortcut and you know they try to
introduce it with Leviathan with those
little mods and then you know with now a
forsaken it's more
University and sending blessing you know
in the city so listen that's nice you
know yeah you get you doing a little bit
more damage that's cool but the reality
is like I said it should be like those
old things for rats and machine things
where it actually helped with the
mechanics of encounters that's what made
it cool so it was really vital to where
that raid set because you would get
those bonuses doing whatever you don't
set activity and I do miss that you know
and I hope they go back to that I felt
like they realized they messed up and
they did a shortcut with this mod thing
well it kind of undercuts itself because
like I said if I have a forsaken armored
set with transcendent blessing I can't
put in another mod that I may want to
use when it should be a feature perk of
the set you know what I mean you're so
um no III think hopefully is something
they addressed I really hope they really
dig down even deeper with the armour
stuff and like I said as well like they
had anything like you know armored
exotic catalysts man that would be so
cool to see how they can implement
something like that to make the armor
feel unique for a special activity like
being on a mod is so different than
having an intrinsic perk that like
uniquely spawns on armor I agree
completely man so would you on that big
time you know I was like yeah so I mean
everybody keep saying mods one other
thing to add for seasoned forward to
give us like two new mods or something
like just throw a couple more into the
mix that'd be nice but the one thing
that I'm thinking about is you said our
wrath of the Machine when things drop
from activities especially like this
raid lair which I know it's a raid lair
and they might have to look at the last
wish but it's like so many of you guys
are still using like you know your
address
not your address and what is it midnight
coup just because it has outlaw and ramp
agents already good what happened to
perks like triple-double like if I'm
gonna get the raid scout and it's got
its exclusive perk that is raid only
those are the other pieces I wanna see
come back and maybe that's like a black
level weapon where it's got its own
piece but those type of perks were
littered that's the only stuff people
would use because those perks were truly
better from that in-game activity than
anything else you could get and they
need to get back to that too I think
well I think that's potentially why
they're gone is like I I'm not
you like I think like wrath and machine
we're like was like the best raid
weapons of all time because they were so
unique they felt so different than other
weapons but but like that's kind of I
think that's what Bungie once avoid is
like everyone using the same weapons I
want more variety and you know when you
have this
yeah the Scout with triple double chaos
dogma I think it was yeah it's like why
would you use any of the sky rifle and
in PvE at least so that I think of
trying to avoid scenarios like that I
mean with the auto rifle genesis chain
they wanted to use any other auto rifle
in PvE you wouldn't right so the cut I
mean then again they do the same damn
thing with the escalation shock and why
are you using no yeah like it's nothing
competin comes close to that shotgun
exactly um yeah it's interesting what
they're gonna do with I'm interested to
see what they do with the new raid lair
stuff yeah I mean it's like the raid is
one of their big selling points I was
like how do you get people in a raid
more give or give you a reason to go in
there so that's as your sense of like a
double-edged sword it's like yeah we
want people to have a variety of weapons
but then if everybody has a good enough
weapon from a Patrol then why do I need
to go run this crazy thing and bash my
head against the wall for six hours so I
don't know I was like yeah it's like
they don't they never have an easy task
of balancing all of this stuff out but I
think we all just want some more variety
and some more vibe if they want us to
have more options again as you said
better than three perks would be nice
yeah absolutely
yeah viaduct will be coming on the 27th
hopefully it's gonna open up a whole new
thing I feel like I can insert the
Aladdin song right there so a whole new
world it fits a full gameplay calendar
we haven't had a calendar in a while
either as well we had the one for season
The Outlaw and now or hopefully we get
something to see what comes we've know
we've got the what is the January event
that I cannot think of right now I've
got it on another picture I'm gonna
cheat running yeah the dawning will be
coming I mean here we'll look at this
right now just cuz it's right here every
mission guns return you got new weapons
which will be good
crucible content iron banner gameplay
update season or inks that's all basic
stuff
the new forges of the chain activity
that's the one everybody's got to know
what that is you've got the black armory
itself
you've got exotics raid lair Legendary's
triumphs and bonus rewards so that's the
big list I don't know what do you guys
it I know we covered a lot on here is
there anything else you want to add
before we kind of move on
no a weird is you know with the dungeon
with shadows was good that was basically
a rate layer like you did not call that
a raid layer and I wouldn't be like cool
ya know except for the fact that I think
if you did it would have to it would
have to have its unique own unique
rewards but if they had its own unique
rewards and they said uh you know
forsaken is coming with a raid and a
raid lair no one would have batted an
eye I think but the existence of that
you know what does that say about black
armory because new raid lair okay so
it'll be you know a rail era type
activity it'll come with its own unique
rewards which is kind of the biggest
factor of being considered a raid type
activity but is there going to be
another dungeon and there's not are
people gonna be expecting that like I
think that's really interesting like
forsaken add so much content that
there's a lot of pressure on block I
mean it's it's expensive as an expansion
but this is not less gonna be pressure
on it to keep bringing a decent amount
of content forward completely agree I
think that that's the key or anything
because one thing that um that we have
to realize like I said is because we
know one is a choose expansion this is
kinda like a smaller update you know do
we
is it fair for us to kind of keep our
expectations lower based on that or
because the stakes are so high they have
no choice but to continue that level of
hunt or forsaken and that's gonna be the
key thing black army I do think it is a
critical DLC I do think there is a lot
behind it just to keep things going you
know and I'm dying to know about these
new forges of the clan activity I'm
dying to see where that goes and maybe
have something on the level which I
thought was great I really don't think
war mine gets enough credit
but war mine is
as much as the the lore and stuff the
story narrative could have been a bit
better I really felt it was a strong DLC
with the with the grind and as far as
the the secrets to ministry Awards you
had sleeper in that you had escalation
protocol in that you know these are
really cool activities man and if they
continue that hardcore grind for for the
you know for our car guys and in
conjunction with that other stuff I
think they've got a shot they've got to
bring it man I do Groot you so something
I've heard about black armory is and is
that a good way to think of it is not
like an expansion it's a Content stream
where this stuff is going it's not like
we're gonna get a lot of stuff on the
fourth but I think stuff is gonna be
rolled out a little bit longer over a
period of time we're kind of like
forsaken we're the height of the
corruption we got a bunch of content
when that you know after three weeks
when that stuff job I think black army
may be doing stuff similar to that movie
cool or we we maybe get like and another
good example you know we didn't get one
of the strikes until the raid was beat
stuff like that where the content isn't
all given on the first day it's rolled
out like oh you have this and this and
this and and it just kind of keeps
people coming back rather than giving
them everything day one and then you
know having everyone get everything done
and grinding through it super fast so
yeah what do you feel about that yeah I
mean it kind of makes sense because you
kind of said you had the right
terminology I guess you there at this
breakneck pace they threw so much at us
with forsaken that for them to be able
to keep up is like kind of crazy but do
they trickle out something you said do
we get access to the black armory then
maybe we get this you know forges the
chain that comes a week later then the
raid lair might get a week or so I mean
I haven't even thought about what the
power levels gonna be if they're gonna
boost it or not like I mean we're at six
now do you go 657 because the longer
that grind was and as they have it
slowed I mean when you go from five 40
to 600 doesn't I mean I'm starting a new
character just to get my third one up
there and it's like it's gonna take a
while so if they have that piece of
they're on top of this stuff if they
trickle a few things out as you guys are
staying just that steady or flow but
maybe not just smash us with everything
that may actually be linked in the use
of the content which is probably
something they're pretty much hoping for
I'm sure I'm just praying that the raid
layer isn't three days after this damn
thing comes out I just make it a week
make it so we can actually even if the
grind is as strong as it is now which it
is very strong like you know if it comes
out a week we just have time to enjoy
the expansion a little bit more I think
what you're i think the problem like you
know Bungie tries to keep everything
hardcore now that they were criticized
for not doing that with destiny to
launch and I think it's important to
remember like you know we like the
hardcore players we'll get there I'll
get there I will get there and I will
open and you know hopefully I can beat
their rate the first day or at least the
first you know week it comes out and I
probably will get there but I'm it's
such a furious grind that you miss other
aspects of the expansion and then you
risk you very much risk getting your
most hardcore players like burnt out if
you make you know play 20 hours a day
you know what I mean that for Sega
grande was real there like that last
crime man the community was it was an
uproar about that's out of my be afraid
little Bella we've got and I feel like I
understand he's coming from you know and
kind of lucky and you know stuff like it
was it was a very interesting handling
of leveling up pre raid and the way they
did it so I'm very curious to see you
know I little I think it was a little
bit too much RNG like I don't mind it
being hard but it was like you get into
scenarios where you would have gear such
that hey if I get a helmet I'm leveling
up five power levels that's insane with
one helmet but if you get gauntlets if
you level up zero you're screwed so you
know you'd get in scenarios where you
got gauntlets twice in a row like that
that's so devastating like that's like a
day of grinding gone like just cuz you
got screwed by our
and so having like no RNG protection
just like some people just ascended so
quickly cuz I got super lucky and some
people just got screwed and I think that
it was handled poorly in that regard I
think it's a little bit RNG protection
or just it programmed in that even if
you get if you get powerful gear and
even if you get gauntlets again and you
gauntlets are your highest item it
should always increase by one so on yes
yes just so it's some sort some sort of
a boost that you're not completely
screwed and you get something less than
what it is so it obviously it'll still
be suboptimal when you get gauntlet you
highest as gauntlets and you get Gaunt's
again so you only go up one but it's
just something and not just something to
make sure you're not completely screwed
by RNG really agree with you and I think
that needs to happen in the algorithm
especially now since if they do release
it in only three days at such a short
time frame that that orangy is gonna
matter so much more like you like you
know you could be unlucky one day and
lucky another day and it kind of evened
out over the weekend a bit of forsaken
until the raid but with only three days
if you're unlucky one day then you're
screwed you're screwed oh yeah I mean
the people who got up to like five 5560
like or were even near 550 for the raid
it's like I mean yeah they probably
grinded their butt off they were doing
the nightfall drops that would like help
every little bit I mean they grinded
their eyeballs out but I did I was over
550 and I like I played like 15 hours a
day grinding yeah so like I mean just to
get to that level was as you said that's
an insane grind for sure so but I mean
also and that's the other kind of
argument we had it's like we had a
addict on here before - it's like the
level of challenges that had and you
guys were the first ones on console that
grind and the feel of that raid for the
first time didn't have the like kind of
amazing feeling the first boss down all
that stuff wouldn't have had that
feeling if you guys would have been 580
much quicker so it's that I mean and
they're walking a delicate line it's
like if they do the three days again it
may not be that high but if they give
you ten days then maybe it'll be more of
a grind
as you guys are saying - it feels really
it's just that psychological hit when
you're like I got something and it's a
complete waste of time let me do my five
crucible matches and get nothing that's
I mean that's an hour and a half
depending on how those matches can go so
you just never know how it's all gonna
be so I think you guys are right like a
little bit at a minimum but it's a
balance of making it still worth what
you get there I watch it because of the
sense that there has to be like like I
said there has to be like again if you
get to duplicate something of something
you don't need it should be like a
one-point thing but I don't want it to
be where the algorithm is just
automatically giving you exactly what
you need and everyone is just flying up
to the new you know I'm saying like mad
at quick I don't want that either so is
that that nice little balance of what
you guys are both saying would be kind
of ideal at least for me yeah yeah so I
mean so we're hoping for we'll see on
the dates of the raid layer I'm I'm with
you Rick I'm hoping it's not three days
you know I mean for whether you're a
content creator whether you're a player
and if you have a notion of even trying
to try that usually like what you end up
doing is you blow through the content so
fast most people want to like skip
cutscenes like your second character
literally just to enjoy the story again
because and there's no benefit to that
they make whatever story is there is let
us enjoy it just a little bit longer so
I'm with you big time on that one
so we'll see what everything comes we
got the 27th for that piece of it let's
see so yeah this will be the annual pass
versus the season you know just the
people with forsaken I guess we'll see
as you guys have saying to wait on it -
is this gonna be the thing that makes
people buy the annual pass right and
that's where the weight comes into all
this decision I think there is a decent
amount of people that's a good point who
are just like waiting yep and saying you
know hey what's this annual pass gonna
be like what's the first expansion gonna
be like and if it's if it doesn't if it
underperforms you know I think that's
you know gonna result in it's just like
they've never done something people
forget is like this is not a normal
expansion they've never done an
expansion like this where it's no fixed
campaign and just a bunch of content
this is the first kind of
this type of X D LA we're ever seeing so
there's a lot of eyeballs on it and
therefore it really does have to perform
yeah big-time big-time this is I don't
think we're out of the woods yet right
Forsaken safe destiny in my opinion and
a lot of the hardcore came back and I
see my friends list playing and that's
great but there is a contingent I know
we're gonna get into the Activision
bunch stuff that um you know that I like
I might wait and see like they feel
burned they feel scarred they feel
betrayed but what how destiny to launch
and its greatest forsaken is I've got
friends that I might do it's in a great
place you need to come back let me see
you know I'm getting that kind of a like
let's see how the next but as to your
point you can't blame them like people
got burned from destiny too and it's
understandable that they're like no I
don't want to come back or they fall in
love with another game like dude
blackouts hella fun I gots so fun like
people come back and and pay another 40
bomb for a game they you know a few
months ago to like facts and to be clear
like I'm with you like I tell people all
the time
I get it like you feel betrayed you feel
like they don't deserve any more
expansion money until you see a
consistent level you know and people
like hey why did they take these things
out at the you know at the start of d2
that were already great at the end of
the one you know it makes sense and
hopefully you know they continue to get
that trust level and um I don't know if
you want to segue down here to the head
child but at that activist bit but of
yeah there's a lot going on and and and
at the end of the day the community I
can't get upset with the community
playing games like black out for it
right right dad there's a lot of good
games out right now people like hey I
don't need to run back necessarily desti
just yet mmm-hmm so we gonna get into it
II the the the faithful quote the topic
I'll be no hype about seeking of a CD
image all right I was muted the same
thing you guys have been talking about
as well
like you got other games you've got uh
and this literally this time last year
coming up in a few weeks is when
everyone got burned by curses like what
is this like infinite forest is so
lackluster the raid layer was shorter
and that was kind of the first raid
layer we've seen and it was apartment 2d
some people did or didn't like it
mercury was the smallest place we've
ever seen it was a circle and the
infinite forest and the strikes that got
duplicated and there were so many things
that worked against that that's why I
mean that whole wait-and-see aspect is
it's real I mean that's not alive but
you've got someone like you know at
Bungie high up saying exactly what he
said so Luke Smith after all this
Activision stuff came out saying you
know they weren't as pleased with you
know results of destiny and its sales
and things like that because dusty - and
forsaken well you may have had 60% of
the player base that was in their game
forsaken you had you know 75% of the
destiny Valerius fall-off you may have
got some back but again it's like that's
a natural thing that happened with curse
of Osiris so now they're saying they're
not disappointed with forsaken we set
out to build a game that destiny players
would love and at Bungie we love it -
building destiny for players who love it
is and will remain our focus going
forward and that is his top tweet right
now he's straight up in that 100 I'm
just gonna open it to you because I know
you gotta go so you go when I saw his
tweet I was high I first off full
disclosure
um further looks Luke Smith is is highly
respected let's get that out you know I
mean this is the guy who was on the
taken King DLC arguably prior to first
second you know one of the deaths the
best content in destiny so you know his
word holds a lot of weight now he did a
little lust at me I'll be honest when on
d2 villain that came out because his
name was also associated I like he was
the sole person I believe was him in
mark Noseworthy but um you know
obviously d2 did what d2 didn't we're
not gonna rehash that but I felt this
was so huge because um you know
obviously the week before me he talked
about the activision call you know Kali
Johnson CLO and them outright saying hey
you know that Forsaken didn't invest
he's not performing like we like
and we know this some truth today I'm
not trying to say the man's a liar the
guy they they have their numbers I get
that you know and maybe they're
projections are much higher but then we
also showed you know the digital sales
were uh we did show its wife our 2017 it
was like a number three or number four
gain in sales so maybe they didn't get
that top spot that they had anticipated
and they voiced it in that way but I
thought this was key for Luke to say
this for two reasons one this is a damn
good piece of content right and I think
the hard core destiny will agree
Forsaken is the best destiny has been in
a long time and um the second thing is
this is pretty ballsy when you speak out
on your boss so to speak in a way you
know it's a tweet but it's a way it's a
it's a defiant step it's me saying look
we're proud of what we did you may not
like you don't think that it's not great
but the community and we're gonna do
well by the fans and I just gained so
much respect for this because literally
when I saw the Activision CEO say we
said that's how I felt like okay I get
what you're saying from a pure number
standpoint you may not you know be
satisfied this is great context I felt
was a little own death in some respects
so I love this look for MOOCs but I just
hope you don't get fired I love this man
and to see the community galvanized and
retweet this thing and it just show like
no yeah I don't know what you're talking
about like if you're trying to force
monetization last but I'm saying I'll
give cactus the floor they're trying to
force monetization that was really what
pissed people off with the CEO of
Activision cuz he's like okay it's
underperforming
so now we gotta find ways to monetize
that's the last thing people want to
hear right now
nobody was faster than the cost nobody
wants to be figuring out ways to throw
money on time that's what got destiny in
trouble you know I'm saying so they
don't it just even ever verse is it a
fairly good place you can get things do
gameplay it's outside of maybe normal
for the most part you know test a out
here hustle it you know say we could get
what we want to get and I just feel like
for him to do this man was so big
interesting keep the essence of bets
making the core happy so that's all I
got to say on it you know I thought it
was like a really cool moment for Bungie
I'm dying to know what the repercussions
are kind of be but it looks like
everyone's behind that's what I got what
about you Rick
I I agree for the most part I think it's
I'm really glad that he said this to say
like look we're not shifting our focus
we think forsaking is good you guys
think forsaking is good we're all on the
same page here I don't think it's
necessarily as defiant as some people
think like I don't like people it's a
big middle finger to Activision like not
necessarily it was an earnings call an
earnings call is just about money you're
talking to the shareholders literally
call an earnings call so you know the
numbers are gonna come out and they had
some internal numbers about how well
they thought forsaken would do and it
didn't hit that goal and so they've got
explain it some way all right they've
got explain it so saying yeah I didn't
perform as well potentially maybe we can
monetize it other ways like it's a lot
of business jargon and it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're gonna
shove microtransactions into the game
because you know they would do that and
of course if we get or they would
attempt to do that they would get
pushback from analysts saying no dummies
like we've done the numbers we've we've
done a bunch of surveys and stuff turns
out if you shove the game full of micros
actions
you're gonna lose even more money
because players are going to leave and
you're saying okay we're not gonna do
that so like I think you got to keep
that in mind is like this is an earnings
call and they've got justify the
earnings and the earnings came up short
like because is something so the
activision itself wasn't necessarily
saying like forsaking his trash or
anything like that but even with all
that being said I still think you know
that Luke Smith came out and said this
when he did not have to because
we work you know the community wasn't
like rallying against destiny we were
almost defending destiny from Activision
saying like like come on guys
yeah the game blew up like you'd think
it could have been also a little bit of
an overzealous prediction of you know
they've got to justify definitely
getting funding from Activision and
saying oh look we're gonna we're
predicting this much I mean it just
might have kind of oversold how much
they were predicting that's a potential
scenario but at the end of the day no
loot again Luke Smith like you said
coming out and saying no you know we
like forsaken and content like forsaken
is what we want to focus on that's so
important mmm like that's so important
and I think you know him also saying
this that is another little hint at
we're not gonna shove the game full of
micro transactions because I mean the
thing is Star Wars Battlefront 2 changed
everything they really show that you
can't just you cannot just do constant
micro transactions and expect people to
take it because they didn't take it and
that game bombed dude that game came out
and I was seeing it not even on a sale
price I was seeing it in like Best Buy
and stuff for 40 bucks
a triple a game for $40 instead of you
know 60 $70 a month after it launched
what I've never seen anything like that
I've never seen anything like that in my
life
so it really showed that you know just
pure monetization isn't the way to go
and you know it kind of died for EA's
sins and now hopefully other games will
not follow suit and not just think that
they can get away with literally
everything reach reach stuff my way feel
what the looks man yeah no I mean I'm so
again I'm glad he tweeted that out so
yeah it was nice to see him I mean he's
got a he's you know wanna high ups a
Bungie he's dealin with Activision
probably fairly directly but he also
wanted to like before we all still you
know pull out the torches and the
pitchforks and go after Activision you
had to be like guys it's like we're
gonna keep what we I mean they've been
making games for forever long
they've learned after these past couple
of years of like what is the what is the
you know community of looking for what
are we going for we actually hit the
nail on the head on this one work and it
keep going in this direction that was a
nice thing to the community but again
ease and but as you catch as you said it
pretty well it's not that middle finger
to Activision it's just saying hey we
thought we did well we're gonna keep
doing that he didn't mention Activision
at all he just said this is what we're
doing and that's I mean even in my chat
says here is like it is a business side
again remember it's the money that keeps
the lights on so Bungie can still make
these games that money right now is
coming from Activision that is just the
contract under and they're it's where
it's coming from I mean they got the big
influx from what is it Nettie's on the
other side they may be working on that
other piece but as for destiny the
business piece of this is just one of
those things and it's as you said they
have to explain it somehow you have
destiny to that comes out to a pretty
decent critical review the annual past I
mean and this is somewhere we're
forecasting may have fallen off to say
hey how many continual active players do
we have how many people fell off like
I've said this before one of my buddies
he's like my gaming dude like he and I
play like everything he did not play
warmind straight-up skipped it and for
him to do that I was like okay him being
burned there's a whole bunch of people
that were much much worse
so when you say forsaken was you know
well reviewed and reasonable like taken
in by so many people that group of
people that started in d2 was much
smaller so I mean this is as you said
answering those questions the game is in
a great spot but it's like the content
base and now we're at a point where
there's so much more competition I mean
you just got done mentioning blackout
which is a ton of fun it's a triple a
battle royale which is the first one in
the realm of battle Royales you've got
red dead that was around the corner and
then a no cactus there's no way you're
not looking around the corner at for
sure I know both anthem and division 2
though it coming up as well
huge right and those like one
straight-up PvE co-op I mean that's like
tried pull and half your raid crew to go
do that that's gonna be straight-up PvE
then you've got the vision depending on
how that comes out if it's we just got
done talking to mark last week like in
Division two Airways division and raised
in general
yes so like all of those pieces are
things they have to look at and take
account of and if in fact it was just
like hey Bungie did this we're doing
this we've got this annual pass to d3
it's like there's so many more pieces
going on right now I think just
forecasting and stuff has got to be
taken into account and it's a point to
where Activision has to justify its
piece but I still kind of wonder if
their expectations were just a little
off track from what we already knew a
player base fell off I mean when so many
youtubers were like oh this that and the
other I'm going away from those are the
signs that like somebody like Activision
needs to be like seeing and go hey this
is this is bad news and this is gonna
affect what's coming in the future and
it was an expansion it's not a deed
number three right that's gonna make
that big influx again so overall I mean
yeah what Luke Smith said is like he
nailed it he's speaking for the
community and saying guys we're not
gonna screw you guys over we're here for
our community because they play this
game as much as we do and I think I
think I think that's such that's such an
important point and I kind of thought of
this as well like that tweet shows the
exact opposite is going on at Bungie
basically then what is going on at
Blizzard right now because it shows that
developers are in touch yes right I mean
we have three community but we have DS
we have dmg we have Cosmo they
participate in community forums they
participate they interact with the
community over at Blizzard they just
announced a mobile game in a room full
of not just hardcore PC gamers but
hardcore PC gamers that are so hardcore
they paid to be there I know I was gonna
go well yeah in that that's being out of
touch with you right that's that's not
knowing what they want like what it was
Luke Smith his tweet we're gonna
continue making dusty to content for
people that enjoy Destin's you content
like that we're what the lives of said
we're gonna make Diablo content for for
people who were gonna make completely
different Diablo content than the people
who enjoy I mean like I again it shows
that Bungie has its finger on the pulse
of the community
much more than some other developers out
there for sure big time
I agree big time last point I'll say it
in reference to it which is like um it's
gonna be curious to see how this thing
plays out because um just long term
because obviously we know the nature
well you know we don't know all the
nature of this deal between Activision
Bungie but you know it's it's
interesting because let's just say let's
just say the game continues to go down a
route with now the hardcore community is
very pleased right and they're
continually doing what we want and we
are having enjoyment of the game right
but then on the flip side let's just say
you know from an earnings perspective
right that it's not doing what
activision wants you know what happens
you know is this a situation where
Bungie looks at themselves and say hey
you know we can't appease too you know
to this to this these guys and you know
do they come up with some type of an
exit strategy long-term you know I mean
we do know they have another game going
on you know we don't we know that there
is a at some point in in to this
contract you know and it would be
interesting like I would never want
money let's be clear like that that's
one of my favorites you know period but
um it is interesting if there is a
disparity between the direction of the
publisher and the developer to the point
where this may be again not saying it is
but let's say down the road create some
sort of riff and then they just not on
the same page so I'm very curious
long-term to see what happens here
thoughts again you know with black army
coming up this is the first of this type
of DLC what are they gonna do what are
they gonna do in terms of ever versus
like we just really have to wait and see
at this point yeah yeah I think that's
that's literally quote running around is
like wait and see what this thing holds
so that's why I kept bugging cocky knows
like I want to see the viaduct I want to
know what it's got because everybody is
on that tipping point do I say tell
people hey go get the annual pass I'm
not gonna know until a week before
potentially and probably most people are
still gonna be like well I'm gonna wait
until somebody gets reviews out there to
say hey is this piece gonna be worth it
because you don't just get to buy black
armory for like ten
you gotta buy the $30 whole thing
there's not even 20 bucks it's a bigger
piece now it's half a full game so you
have to commit for the whole year just
to get the first piece of it so people
that's why the wait I think is heavily
on this first part to set the bar to no
and I mean different pieces could have
different levels of you know scales of
content and stuff like that like the
season of the Joker I don't think if you
just do a whole thing about gambit can
be nearly as big as this like black
armor and weapon type and machine goes
like that's gonna be the bigger piece
like the other ones later might not
impotent the numbers get farther to go
but all in all I'm with you guys just
like it's it's a wait-and-see it's like
crossing our fingers but as you said we
haven't seen this type yet so we won't
know until we get it
mm interesting pants man
so all of that out there we might you
know dip back in that well but for now
moving back on through the 12 flip of
the coin did you guys get a chance to
see I have not actually watched this
gambit stream yet I keep meaning to and
I keep forgetting about it have you guys
watched I was busy I was busy tests I
was busy testing a new Astro controller
I think that thing I've seen that video
out there on your channel do you like it
so far it feels it actually feels pretty
good and you know it's nice that there's
another kind of big player in those
controller in the controller market like
someone someone engages me at Twitter
and was like oh you know if anyone's
trying to tell you that the you know
they you know that not to just use the
normal base ps4 controller you waste you
money and I was like dude you realize
like you actually get a pretty big
advantage and remember him he's like oh
we're like what kind of things you get
like you just didn't know I think a lot
of casual players don't know but like
having those back paddles or in the
Astro controllers buttons it's buttons
on the back being able to use those and
jump and then aim without taking your
thumb off the thumb stick is so
advantageous in a game like destiny
because normally you'd have to like take
your thumb off the thumb stick press
jump then move it back on and aim and so
just like you see an enemy you jump then
you have to like go you know go back to
thumb stick and then a with the
but being able to you know jump while
aiming at that enemy I mean every single
like competitive player has you know
stuff for something like that to allow
you to do that it's so advantageous in
crouching as like sliding as well and so
you get so much more performance but
again right now
you know stuff is definitely the big
player and skew be really interesting to
see how astro does like I mean you know
a lot of people have asked our headsets
in there and they're really really good
quality so you know saying hey the
people who make that the headsets that
everyone like absolutely loves are now
making a controller like that's a big
deal
and it feels really good to be honest
like having actually played with it
feels it feels very very good actually
two questions actually from my chat
they're asking um one for luck did see
you in rock that look it look fantastic
gave me an arm in the leaked and Xbox
elite controller feel which I love is
with my favorite controllers as far as
the mapping I love how you was able to
swap just so simply you know the analog
to the d-pad make position by just quick
that's such a big issue and people
that's me rising lee so big like hey you
can swap it to Xbox configuration with
the thumbs XP pillai k-- oh my like it's
so huge people really have strong
preferences for those little things you
won me over when you did that I was like
oh this is the sec the question now is
awesome oh he's asked he said is it
confirmed that the Astro controller
doesn't have motion controls I don't
that's unique to Sony do we have like
that motion thing and involved with it
or we haven't tested it just yet what
does he mean by like motion controller
like a gyroscopic thing that they they I
can't speak for Astro but I don't
remember anything about motion controls
like the thing like it was mainly just
the design of the controller but
honestly one of the big things is the
software like you can you plug it into
your PC and then you can change all the
all it's fully remappable all from there
um and so you don't you know you don't
have to have to buy you like scoff you
have to not only buy the control you
have to get the electronic remapping I
made the mistake of not getting one with
luck trying to do mapping and it could
not change the buttons I do buy a whole
new one like that's some BS so after you
don't
ever have that you can just change from
the computer but like the software is
not just like Oh change the buttons you
can adjust the sensitivity of your
thumbsticks of your trigger pull you can
make it select you like breathe on the
triggers and it goes like full tilt
shoots it right away basically you can
make the thumbsticks so like you can
make it more sensitive off the beginning
so you can flick on people you can make
it a little bit less sensitive at the
beginning so you have a little bit of a
dead zone if you have kind of a little
bit like a twitch or if you just don't
want it you know interacting for no
reason so you can change like you know
long you can change the sensitivity in
different levels at which you pull it
that's insane that's insane like that
level of customization it literally into
me like four guys on the Xbox side who
have lead controller that's the level I
like in that cassette paddles on the
bottom and you can just mash the other
buttons and buttons right okay buttons
right which is really interesting I
didn't think I'd like but I do like them
and and I think buttons like thing about
buttons like paddles can bend and they
can soften and they can move out of
alignment buttons are a lot more like
simplistic they're way less chance of
breaking you know just press a button
you know so I I'm glad the buttons feel
as good as they do because just the
nature of being a button is just more
resilient than being a paddle yeah
absolutely absolutely it looks great it
looks great people are Heitmann we just
got to find out from slo-mo if they cat
boat sees all what do you want to do
motion controls for bro know about like
I mean things like in until dawn or
Detroit for example because I know I
played that when you literally move the
whole controller to like gesture
basically and it's not in a ton of stuff
but I guess it's more just compatibility
across the board is what they're
wondering about because there are
they're on a ton but there are a few
things that do use it so if somebody
wants to switch over and honestly for
something like that you're not gonna go
for that elite feel you already have
your main controller if you're like if
you're playing Detroit you're not going
for that you know you're not trying to
like he knows how I'm like that yeah
yeah so you're not trying to do anything
crazy like that so yeah so just play use
your normal controller for that but if
you want that as you say the elite
advantage not moving your thumb off
everything yeah there's no reason not to
honestly the thing is like you're going
against people who do have that
advantage is the problem right so you
you are like if you've ever wonder how
does guy get me how does he keep you
know
in midair how's how's he like
outperforming me probably and you're
using a base controller like I do as
like the number-one thing to like just
it does it have one thing to up your
game pretty substantially it's just like
a better controller it's a huge event
just I mean the rapid trigger stuff and
have huge Judas so I really helped my
and like I said I'm an average crucible
player but it really helped my game and
I'm like wow I see the difference right
now so yeah we're gonna plug that thing
for you but that thing looks nice it's
real smooth over here if you want to if
you want to pre-order affiliate links
work so go to his page he's got those
the links will be down in the
description guys it is like a kind of a
big announcement I'm very excited that
again another big player has n told the
entered the controller like custom
controller market I think that's like
we're a really big deal in gaming
because if you don't like stuff you
don't have too many other places to go
mm-hmm you to it I was literally gonna
say they're the only one but yes exactly
some kind of smaller things but like
yeah you don't have very like you don't
have a lot of other options so it's
really exciting anytime there's like a
big another option for gamers out there
with anything really yeah yeah I agree
man I agree and home.look way I'm a huge
fan - cause I've always they're always
[ __ ] they've done quality work they've
got a good representative right now so
she'll let the cowboy W it from the a 50
days they've always had high quality so
it's real cool to see them jump in that
space where there's not a lot of
competition and it give gamers options
that's what we want right we want
options you want to see what else we can
get out in this like even even though
we're dusty players we're all like yo
division 2 and oh my goodness like what
you know what's gonna happen it's gonna
be crazy cuz Italy no that's the
competition there's a lot of other
options now for those people who love
those loop-based games
facts a competition Oh
benefits the game that fat makes destiny
have to step it's game huh you know
these are other games have to step their
game up now because of destiny
this is all a cycle that benefits us and
it's good to see mm-hmm anyway after
that giant derail but we're back
probably haven't before but like we call
it flash point but literally the flash
should be in quotes because this always
turns into a long point so on podcasts
are never short my goal is just to delay
this podcast as much as possible and
just yeah I'm just basically made
ruining your guys's Saturdays so that's
why I'm here right
my wife is literally doing something
else I could sit here for three hours
let's go today let no bully me I was
like Tristan the more time we got you on
here we're having a blast so I'm good
but anyway we were talking about gambit
there's the gambit stream but there are
some things coming to season 5 for
gambit so I wanted to get you guys
thoughts on these some of them have
people have some thoughts on of course
opinions are out there but they've been
closely monitoring game but we have our
ups and downs you know the solo the
singles the melting of bosses all that
type of stuff is stuff they've been
thinking about so gambit bounty is for
one there gonna be a little changes to
them the rank points rewards for your
bounties your dailies are gonna be
doubled which is good we've got numerous
dailies daily challenges have their
objectives returned to take less time to
be easier so it's easier to do those
bounties so infamy will go a little
faster and then also there's a new
bounty this is probably the coolest ones
to kill primeval on voice I'd love ya
only getting I cannot wait for that so
that one's huge because there's so many
people that I wanted to scream on my
screen you know I'm sitting there
playing with random like shoot nf
everybody's done this just shoot the
ongoing I can't do anything about it
so you feel ya you feel like you have to
do it yourself sometimes very happy they
did that to kind of trick the
blueberries into actually helping it's a
nice way to teach just oh what's this
what do I do here mmm-hmm Oh which is
Prem evil Slayer bounty Oh Slayer
benefit oh I doing more damage Oh
see those are some of the little things
I wish though and bunchy sometimes likes
to keep things vague and I've heard
people ask for this before like on your
first like play your first match of
guarantee on a batch of gambit I can't
talk sorry that happens at some point
you know that as well as all of us when
you play that first match have it come
back out and like go over a couple
things in that interest screen be like
all right you've seen gambit these
primeval envoys give you this this
multiplier does this just for those
first people to see like a little
tutorial in the game just so those
people who are kind of clueless might
get a bit more of a clue I think might
help a little bit sometimes for stuff
like that we could just skip right over
it but some of those little pieces would
help your newbies as you said the
blueberries get a little more of a link
yeah or just primeval Slayer itself it's
kind of a little tiny thing in the
bottom maybe make it a little bit more
noticeable yeah that hey there's some
sort of benefit going on here you know
or just like that bosses health put like
at times to giant time sewer times three
sitting them next to it be like okay
this is something's going on here like
to watch and notice some would be cool
little UI stuff like that might be nice
infamy rewards subdivision is what
they're they now award gambit legendary
so not just the blues
every little subdivision is gonna give
it the legendaries which is nice let and
then the primeval catch up now I just I
mean basically they're gonna work on
tweaking this in a lot of ways don't get
to in a second but for you guys I just
want to get your thoughts on either
burning the catch up your thoughts and
playing with randoms and groups like how
do you guys feel the catch up is
balanced right now before they touch it
look I could drop one is first I gots my
thoughts oh man uh it's really hard to
say like the ketchup can be your
downfall of like you know people a
little bit behind they have one good
envious like even slightly good invasion
and then they just come in there
primeval a little bit later and like
even if they don't even kill you just
they delay you and that invasion and
then they get a benefit and they melt
their guy and you're kind of like I was
robbed at the same time it's nice to be
able to come back like if they're some
of their primeval and then you do have a
good invasion and you kill them you heal
you know their guy and then your guys
start melding them
so that's really fun but yeah I I
honestly couldn't say we're gonna have
to see how these new changes really play
out by testing it for a while and see if
it's it's better cuz you know it really
there's so many differences just in one
game of gambit to the other depending on
the team compositions and so on and just
random stuff like hey you went through
the portal at the right time the entire
enemy team is standing in a good
position to be hit like your game is
gonna go way differently than if you
come out and you spawn into an area that
where you can't see the enemy team and
they kind of realize you're there and
they hide and whatever like it's just so
many different factors in gambit that
you know we got it's hard to say like Oh
changing the ketchup mechanic will for
sure help in this many ways it's gonna
be interesting I'm glad they're tweaking
stuff like that I'm glad they're trying
to find like the best possible way and
if you know if this is worse than they
can always go back and stuff like that
but I like that it's not just like
static and they're like oh this is the
way it is I like how they're messing
around with stuff like that
yeah I'm literally on the same page I
think that um it's one of those things
that I could say like I can say there's
so many variables you know it would
gambit and um you know offhand match is
where I felt is that great tug of war
you know to me where they come in
getting some clutch kills and you
getting those clutch eels and stuff like
that
and a few times I felt like hey like so
does it start it like their prime even
was just melted you know the opponent
like okay again it's one of those things
that we have to see it implemented see
how it you know how it plays out and
again it's really cool that they're
actually looking at this data we know
from a standpoint from the weapons they
nourish my baby
there's my baby but it was never a baby
sleeper you know saying that's my baby
right there but again it was me you know
to get more a little bit more viability
with other weapons and stuff like that
so Queens breaker now like I wore Joe
hey I don't have it yet so I just I'm
only getting smoked still so I am NOT on
the Queen's breaker bandwagon and I have
one it's it's touched yes I don't know
it's unreal when you're invading or
getting invaded until you melt your
prime evil and if you're out
escalation rounds you're like oh I'll
shoot it with my Queens burger oh it
does like no damage sleeper sleeper is
so good like like in the sense that if
you do get lucky with ammo and you you
know you're at the end of a round with
five sleeper shots you can just pump
those into primeval and they do a ton of
damage it's insane man so you got that
it's just like I said it's cool to see
them still tweak and then also
overarching thing if they're doing all
this now we're we're not even that was
it the season of The Joker yet right
which is right
my understanding like a huge gambit
overhaul in conjunction to maybe some
type of additions to the mode oh just
slightly I think what's gonna happen is
that with this season of when the
drifter expansion comes out you know how
when you click crucible it opens a new
menu and all these other sub sub game
modes come out and I think you can see
some stuff similar to that with gambit
or there's gonna be like a few different
types of gambit like maybe there's a
kind of gambit where there's like you
know a bank and a primeval but there's
no two separate Maps like everyone's
just on the same map all the time so
you're constantly like trying to make it
to the bank like let's say you only have
to Bank like 25 modes and then summon
the primeval
and then whatever team kills at first
whatever team gets the last damage on
the perm evil wins the game like they're
gonna be stuff like that right up just
different kind of game types within
gambit just like there's different
crucible game types mmm almost like
going back to like a prison and olders
what if it's just one team and you're
going for like a score piece as well can
you go fast can you burn it down can you
work like every version of ganged up -
yeah that'd be cool yeah we cool we kind
of give you a way to practice as well
but give you scoring give some other
stuff like you know give your infamy
ranks or whatever same idea so yeah I
like that
they'd open up more options yes yes I
like I said just going in the lab
tweaking adding stuff figuring things
out I'm all about I think we can all say
the motifs itself as a success you know
when I was at e3 and I got a chance to
play it early I knew they had something
and I'll shout to who I was just playing
with uh the art the RG in the fire team
chat guys Destin
we're on the same team and we looked at
each other like you know this is gonna
be something you know say okay this is a
mold it's PvP PvE mix it's a good
balance and then on top of it which I
think they don't get enough credit for
and check out the cactus with his videos
on the gambit our weapons right when you
rank them that like um I just think my
place nobody get weapons are like the
best to be game like I got my hands in
the cast I got my guards you know I
still be looking for my god role on what
is it bad omens I believe yep
that or the curator alone I lead they
see right now the only tracking cluster
in the game I got a bootleg one I got a
xenovia which has the hacky the
intrinsic track II a little bootleg that
over there I work yeah I've not been
that lucky in rocket launchers mine are
mostly trash yeah yeah like I really
feel that's another thing that makes the
most wrong because again is a nice
loophole and I know me and you Yvonne
chest have talked about this a lot like
you know I would love if climb well had
a reason to go in there you know I mean
because it's really no good rewards
associating with like how like
escalation protocol is and stuff like
that so I think it's in a good party
games in a good place and I just like
T's constitutes weeks and stuff like
that's pretty cool yeah I mean I'm with
you guys like the modes fun but fur I
just keep wondering I think that's
probably a really good way to think of
it like it's gonna have its own director
bubble different things in it but I've
been I've been sitting there racking my
head I'm like are they gonna bring like
more boss varieties in there is it
always gonna be taken as the primeval is
they gonna have some mix-up for that
maybe there's like a weekly like crazy
version that's like curated I don't know
like I'm still curious to see what they
do because Gambon itself is cool I just
don't know how they do an entire
basically content release or stream as
we've been talking about either way over
just mostly focused on that so that'll
be that'll be intercept to is like
that's the focus but then there'll be
obviously new strikes they'll be new
weapons they'll be no crucible maps like
they're gonna expand all aspects of the
game except for like I'm just gonna be
the focus and but yeah it's gonna what
new how they can expand it we'll have to
wait and see that's a good tagline wait
and see that's what the
quote on this banner Thank You cactus
for coming in let's wait and see for
this podcast
oh yeah just yeah they said for example
like the instance they said for the
ketchup mechanics they said like if the
leading Hume has seven the other team
would get four it's literally gonna be
one so we're just gonna have to kind of
get a feel for what these changes are
gonna do if the if the ketchup is now
gone or can you make that difference
again so because as you if it's a
stacked team and you've got two
geomatics table it like is it that the
chaos are each crazy okay we start out
one guy so where you have like two of
those like and or something like I mean
that's just beat you could even do one
stack and probably still melt them down
so but yeah the whole soul over on Team
Q is a whole different thing but I think
more than most other modes I mean PvP
iron banner you feel it but I do think
the four stack for us the solos I'll win
and lose some but I know when I'm
against a team every time so I play a
lot of solos but double infamy is next
week so you don't miss that guys double
infamy is the first part of the week
basically Tuesday to Friday and then
Friday to Monday it will be 11 to be
determined it's probably when they're
patch time comes but triple infamy over
Thanksgiving weekend afterwards so you
got some downtime get some triple in to
me when I get away from your family
getaway grab some into me well yeah
patch notes they basically did say if
you guys are working for rankings in
night falls or Valor or glory or infamy
all of these are going to reset on the
27th so any grinding that you're doing
now do it like especially for that week
before the 27th if you're trying to get
your second package from gambit or
anything like that now is the time put
that time in the Boyer's back to zero so
don't forget about those pieces I'm like
one and a half steps away it's got to
get those BAM Carney class matches then
of all three different modes
please be yeah I mean that is most of
the 12 I think
well except for the December 4th black
armory lunches so I'm sorry where's that
little line where they literally
invested there it is
yeah so literally a heck of a week in
recent weeks some players have noticed
that season
forge begins on the 27th of a black army
drops available on November 4th that's
the only place yeah December 4th sorry
no how do they do that how do they drop
that there sir Twitter it's so hidden in
the dam up days like December 4th like
thanks it makes the most sense I mean
what like yeah November 27th this is a
Tuesday and then that's just the
following Tuesday like it when I heard
November 27th that was kinda like ok so
the 4th but so it's confirming what we
kind of thought but still kind of buried
it's the depth the subtlest way they've
ever announced a date for anything ever
is right here mid mid-sentence just not
even I mean there's not even an
indention or a picture or anything it's
just there so at I don't even know what
to think of that besides they're just
trying to let people have Thanksgiving
off and then they'll come back and blow
the doors off it on the 27th we'll see
see but yeah I don't you have anything
to say about that thing being hidden
there Cognito before I uh it was
interesting it's just like yeah let's
just slide this in here without no
hoopla like all right it was adjusted a
bit chose to do it this way I know this
kind of goes to your whole I don't say
frustration but I know you've been on
them a little bit about like you guys
got to get the you know the height train
going and um not even a high dream going
I think sorry interrupt but there's a
little bit of a difference between that
getting the hype train going and just
letting players know like people will
book off time from work for this people
will you know schedule vacations
differently like people will you know
they want to be around and they want to
be playing yeah when it first comes out
and like wait I think you could have
dropped that December 4th maybe they
legit don't know and they're making it
but I really like when dates are dropped
earlier so you can always prepare for
that like you know when things are
coming and you don't have to necessarily
a company that date with a trailer you
can just give players that dates they
have that knowledge right it almost a
viper gives me it almost feels like it
was a mistake like they thought they may
have mentioned it earlier in the 12 and
it's like you know just reiterating
something that should have been
technically you
highlighted much earlier that's the vibe
I got because I'm like how do you just
roll this in the sentence at the very
bottom you know Oh blah like it just
seems weird so that's the vibe I got
like someone may have or they knew they
would mention it and then everyone would
like tweet it out and they're just like
whatever that's a mistake depend on
Twitter it's like you need like Twitter
some YouTube's like give just give all
the you know content creators out there
that one graphic that says black armory
December 4th and then that will spread
the word but that's not even there just
one image with the date true that that's
like because they love a lot of content
creators do the work but yeah it's like
you guys are gonna start custom making
images basically to do that you guys do
have any known issues for destiny for -
for second I got a couple of them up
there you see you guys can look in there
and read over those they've got their
general movies of the week always fun
ones to watch but down here they do
mention the last wish right along will
be on Monday so that will be 1 8 1 p.m.
Eastern Time for you guys out there in
the East Coast 10 a.m. Pacific you guys
haven't seen a read-along check them out
or at least go check the Twitter stream
later because if you you know if you're
okay being spoiled on the raid it's cool
to see the developers talk about the
details of it as they go through it
Cosmo get may get fired again we don't
know
he literally tweeted that he's like oh
boy like cuz he saw that he's like yeah
Cosmo is getting thrown on the bus which
is good because especially helps cuz
yeah Dylan wrote this one but they did
say what do they say just a few more
heroic missions fresh premiere and then
I'll have my purple bar all that stems
like don't forget this weekend is iron
banner triple valor where did they say
the one thing where they're gonna take a
little time off I saw it in there they
said I was gonna tell saying like next
week is gonna be kind of the beginning
the holiday season there isn't gonna be
much info coming out so that's kind of
22 kind of like I guess 19 to like yeah
like so next week 19 22 the 24th and
stuff and then and then starting with
the 27th they're gonna release the video
and that that following week twice seven
to the fourth is it gonna be like the
big chunks of info that's not to say
there might not be a treatise or
something that comes up
for the 27th but starting to 27th
they're really pushing the hypetrain
basically sir yeah see man you see that
that Dublin Bungie Studios I think my
twitch streams get to get this thing
going man get to get because like I said
we all agree we do feel this is black
harmonies very critical they need to hit
another one you know same ain't have to
be a homerun majestic of course they can
but definitely something solid to keep
everybody - engage nice leadoff double
you know get the end and going really
going but yeah if we look ahead on the
annual pass we've got season and drifter
no new weapon type of course the new
weapons crucible iron banner that's like
that's copy and pasted a couple times
over Joker's wild sorry I called it the
wrong thing new activity experience
that's that same thing so I'm gonna be
really curious to see what that whole
activity of the forge is the forges of
the chain activity because that's
another activity
gambit evolves and then no raid layer
with this one so that's again where
feels like gambits really got its weight
and then we have all the stuff of the
redacted going back to Calais which
feels a little weird and all that stuff
coming up so we've got more later but I
guess we've got to wait and see what
this one does have to hold because we've
got a lot but I did want to ask I know
where to get in towards the end of this
we usually open another can of worms as
we go as well so for all of our guests
that we have out there on flashpoint
cactus this is for you it's definitely
just to put you right on the spot oh
it's gonna work all of your time and
destiny of which you're like all of us
we've had a ton get miss your top three
experiences experiences moments that
want like those top three in all of
destiny but you've got it all through
this is this lets in now oh you talk
just D 2 or D 2 and E 1 2 and E 1 like
okay III got think now so you'd like an
example from one of us or does that help
no no no not number three just curious
number three a combination between me
thinking that it would be a waste
of strange coins to get the Gjallarhorn
because it would be it was gonna be it's
a heavy weapon I was like you can use a
primary weapon so much more and being
part of that train that just had no clue
over top the very start we just didn't
know
and then actually getting the
Gjallarhorn from the hole to class like
that was and like that was so lit number
two
geez I think let's go number two I think
it's just like like just the general
being in age of triumph like age of
triumph which is such a good send-off
and like the game was so complete at
that point and it was like all these
raids are relevant and like it was just
really really fun some of the best
looking gear - I missed that yeah having
a new raid like every week and stuff
like just so that'd be my number two
just like the the the experience and the
general feelings of when age of [ __ ]
came out and like it was just like such
a good send-off to d1 and then number
one I think number one is going to be
recently number one is when we beat like
me and n coach and and my team rate team
we beat the last wish raid and we ended
up being the first team in the world on
console and I was freaking sweet
that was awesome for you guys - so you
guys were truly like number one on
console it's like that was amazing from
that I hope yeah I got those raid
jackets oh well I've actually got it yet
but I ordered it we'll see when it
actually comes that jacket looks so
crispy it looks so clean there as soon
as we beat it as soon as we beat it we
were getting offers to its for people to
buy it oh my god hey aka can I cop that
jacket from you buddy yeah I was
like hell no I'm wearing this to church
to sleep these are my new pajamas might
be too hot
yeah you gonna fry in that thing but
yeah next time you go to next time you
head north or something definitely bust
that thing out when you walk in the
Bungie doors be like sucks it's like I
did this I'm one of those that's you ya
know that's a that's a hell of a list
right there that's an awesome top three
especially your top one that's yeah
world's first at 80 yet like I've never
even been close to one of those so no
that's that's an amazing one okay cuz
what was the highest amount of money you
were offered for that rain jacket they
did they it was my team members it was
like kind of the quote/unquote randoms
on my team they were getting offered
they they didn't try to go after I think
me and n couch because they're like oh
there they didn't want to mess with us
but my teammates are getting some
messages right jackets and so on I
forget like how much money they're being
offered but more than they ever should
have been basically dude it's so it's a
dud - because it's like what are you
gonna walk around there a jacket then
someone's like wait did you run down the
road yeah bro look up rain report no you
easiest exposure what it is you're right
no that is stupid I think what it is I
think for me personally the jacket is so
fire like it is something I would wear
you know I'm saying so I think that in a
combination you got your little logo
there's a bungee thing now yeah he's
gonna look like a clown you know because
the name's not on it and you know and
clearly not world's first but I just
think people got high for the design now
do you guys get the belt also the belt
just for like world's first overall oh
we got nothing for being world's first
on console like in terms of being first
for anything got shoes but yeah we
should all get okay
got it not see any differential still
with that jacket jacket well I was like
this has been awesome thank you for
coming on accident
I was like your explosion as of in this
past year has been awesome I know you've
been enjoying the ride but it's
definitely cool to watch as well so
definitely keep doing everything that
you're doing I was like and any haters
and stuff out there
honestly like dad's like I know it's
like you do it enough you'll have a
thick skin you do you the bigger you are
the more hate that you're gonna get and
so it's like one of the coolest things I
am it's like I don't want to call out
harp on it much but it was just after
like stuff has happened at the community
and I'm not gonna bring up what it is
but just the interaction between two
that like two of the elites out there
literally like glut you and glad just
the tweets that you guys shared to each
other was exactly what this community
always brings and you guys were both
positive to each other supporting each
other and that was that was the bring
around to say hey guys doesn't matter
what you do and just have fun enjoy it
and be positive and I think that was one
of the coolest things I saw recently was
you to do that yeah games are about fun
absolutely the last thing I want to
double down to it's just there like I
definitely feel like firstly arises when
tremendous justjust keep putting out
that great content huge fan of your vs.
series huge fan you know when you bring
those new weapons or new exotics you put
them through the paces you put them
through the Ray you see how effective it
is that stuff is really good man you do
a fantastic job with that and the thing
I give you a lot of credit you know a
lot of people we love this game but at
the same time you have to be honest
about things when we don't like it and
one thing about you I feel you like the
pioneer of that in the sense of like oh
you're gonna call it oh it is God is
gonna call out it you're gonna say how
he feels you know I'm saying we need
more of that we you know we don't want
to just gloss things over if things
don't feel right stuff like that for you
do a tremendous job and he a real one
man I've been a guardian Kyle when I
rolled up on your bed - he's like wow
really
thank you for doing this for jumping on
flashpoint thank you for the previous
appearance on our island loss podcast
man means a lot to us and like I said a
lot of the little guys we aspire to get
to where you go and keep up the
fantastic work ethic it's a great job I
appreciate it though though but yeah
that's pretty much where we're gonna
wrap it up
cactus not as though everybody doesn't
know where you are ready but you want to
leave where people can find all your
greatness out there
the world so good on a vein you find me
if you find me
you gotta get Hollywood that out is the
tad plug baby well if you guys don't
know where is that bulimic between uh
between all of our tweets you'll find
them out there and definitely go check
him out solid content on besties and
other games as well so all the stuff
coming up in the future he's definitely
gonna be one of your main sources guys
to stick with them he will be the one
that will give it to you straight so I
think that's where we wrap it up you
guys know for me it's a bond test
everywhere YouTube twitch Twitter it's
you know where to find me and then for
you kognito it's every sunday is the
lord's day iron Lords podcast we got 11
a.m. Eastern during football season got
a cool dance we got our mats gaming so
we're gonna be breaking down everything
that's going on with the madness of the
Peter Sony skipping III you've got this
list X boxes to talk about so it's gonna
be a fun show you already know like I
said on my podcast channel Sunday 11
a.m. Eastern Standard Time and of course
flashpoint with my main my destiny
brethren these bots is every Friday
normally at 9 a.m. but especially
especially Saturday edition because we
had cactus in the building but yeah I'm
just gonna talk this destiny stuff
what's going on in community and all
that good stuff and once again thanks
for uh cactus for coming through there's
a lot of fun sir thank you so that is
well wrap it up thank you guys and Chad
it's been great and as always we'll see
you guys next week
but thanks thank you again Rick thank
you for coming it's definitely a big
closure I doubt anybody enjoy a Saturday
but alright these